tonight's nominees for an outstanding  performance in a lead role are you want  me to do it by memory  Woody Allen any Hall Richard Burton and  necklace Richard Dreyfuss and goodbye a  girl  my cello Mastriani a special day  a John Travolta in Saturday Night Fever  and the winner is a new heavyweight  champ richard rifle  I didn't prepare anything uh wait a  second am I here yes okay first I will  embarrass Ray Stark by saying that I owe  him everything and he is a great man -  herb Ross who is the only true gentleman  I've ever known in my life - herb Marsha  and Neil and Quinn I could go on and on  and on and I don't want to leave can I  rent this now thank you very much